drei arten wie freund schauen dass ich
sie denn ihnen schaffen enden können ja
das ist bei mädels haben erschien das
ist ein kanal von funk und 5 ist es
konnte ein netzwerk von ard und zdf für
junge menschen wenn ich das hier
freundinnen schaffen dann habe ich mich
erst mal gefragt mein bester freunde die
ich erst ein mann ich bin eine frau soll
ich jetzt unsere freundschaft eine
freundin schafft nennen oder eine
freundschaft nennt das thema ist
eigentlich viel größer als ich darüber
lustig zu machen weil das zu ändern ist
sexistisch ländern benötigt nämlich eine
sache die eigentlich gar nicht mehr en
vogue ist und zwar dass man genau auf
das geschlecht zeigt man sagt du bist
eine frau und du bist ein mann in
england zum beispiel gilt das wort
actros als sexistisch weil auch das
geschlecht verwiesen wird wenn ich doch
eigentlich in den beruf gehen soll und
deswegen sage ich schluss mit der
sendereihe schluss mit der freund innen
schafft denn das ist sexistisch